reescribe la expresión 4 por 8 3 usando
la propiedad distributiva de la
multiplicación sobre la suma después
simplifica la expresión hay dos maneras
de resolver esto vamos a ver las dos
maneras voy a reescribir aquí con código
de colores 4 por lo que está entre
paréntesis que es ocho másteres cuando
tenemos algo entre paréntesis nuestra
inclinación es resolver primero lo que
está adentro de él y después lo que está
afuera en este caso es evaluar esta
expresión que es 8 2 3 11 y luego eso
multiplicarlo por lo que está fuera 4
por 11 es igual a 44 pero nos piden usar
la ley distributiva de la multiplicación
no sólo evaluar la expresión como lo
acabamos de hacer así que primero vamos
a multiplicar y luego hacemos la zona y
esta propiedad se llama distributiva
porque vamos a distribuir en este caso
el 4 en el 8 y en el 3 nos va a quedar 4
por 8 más
4 x 3 esto es igual a 8 por 4 32 más 3
por 42 los sumamos y que nos da pues nos
va a dar igual que en el anterior 44 lo
que hicimos fue distribuir este 4 con el
8 y después con el 3 y después hacer la
suma de ambos resultados visualicemos lo
que está pasando aquí voy a dibujar 8
cosas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y a esto le voy a
agregar tres cosas más y aquí tengo 11
cosas en total esto es lo que tenemos
dentro del paréntesis cuando
multiplicamos todo esto por 4 que es lo
que va a pasar de hecho voy a copiar y
pegar para no tardar demasiado
copio esto y lo nuevo aquí está otra vez
y nos falta multiplicarlo una vez más
muy bien que es esta parte que estoy
subrayando acá o encerrando aquí pues
esto es 8 sumado asimismo 4 veces o lo
que es lo mismo 8 por 4 s
4 x 8 esta parte de acá cada uno de
estos se suman entre sí y este 8 por 4
nos da el 32 y ahora qué es lo que
tenemos acá esto de aquí pues es 3
sumado asimismo 4 veces esto más esto o
lo que es lo mismo 3 por 4 3 por 4 es
igual a 12 y es así que vemos por qué se
cumple la ley distributiva tanto el 8
como el 3 se suman 4 veces cada uno